as the world slowly begins to recover
from the past year which was terrible
not just because of kovid but because of
the many many weak anime titles
there has been one shining light that
continues to get stronger than ever
demon slayer the movie mugen train
the bright flame of rengoku has pushed
the movie to heights never before seen
within the realm of anime
surpassing spirited away as the highest
grossing anime film in japan and just
recently the highest grossing
in the world with its international
debut
and of course i had to see it in
theaters i felt obligated to
it's not often that anime comes to
theaters let alone such a huge and hyped
movie like mugen train
so i threw on my tangible robe and
treaded carefully into the theater of
masked hooligans through ruling over
nezuko and the love hashira
unaware that i was about to witness one
of the greatest spectacles of anime to
have ever
existed yeah it was awesome
like any hype that was built up for it
it went above and beyond what i was
expecting
and so if you thought that i was
questioning this in the title that i
didn't think it was good
it's the complete opposite i was a huge
fan of this movie
and i feel like most people were and i
wouldn't even say that i'm a huge fan of
the demon slayer series
i've read the manga enjoy the anime and
i'm always a fan of ufotable just
because the fate series that they've
done
is one of my all-time favorites but i
wouldn't say demon slayer is a
particular favorite anime of mine
so the amount that i enjoyed this movie
genuinely surprised me because i loved
it
whether it was because it was the first
movie i've seen in theaters
in well over a year or just because it's
objectively great
i'm going to dive into all of that plus
the movie plot and my critique of it
today in this video
before we get rolling though just know
that i will avoid major spoilers as i
talk about the plot so if you haven't
watched it
you can still watch this video and also
make sure to hit that subscribe button
if you haven't already
a huge chunk of my viewers aren't subbed
yet so it would help the channel out a
lot
let's go
the first thing that i want to mention
about the demon slayer movie is
how cohesive it is with the series as a
whole
with such big shonen series we see it
with my hero and its recent movies as
well as
i mean all of the big three but it's
very typical that the movie will just be
filler
it'll be an attention grabber just for a
bit of money to promote the series
one of the reasons i have a very hard
time watching shonen anime movies is
because they
always just feel like pointless eye
candy you know that everything is going
to be exactly the same at the end
because the studio is
literally not allowed to make any canon
changes but the demon slayer movie
is an integral part of the series
covering honestly one of my favorite
arcs in the entire manga
and it covers the mugen train arc very
well never once did i feel like this
movie was dragging on
literally once you get to act two of the
movie it is a train that never stops
moving for one second
until the movie ends in an incredible
blaze of glory
no pun intended what i also love about
this arc is how great it works stand
alone in a movie format instead of as a
season
it starts after the very slow end to the
first season where the general
acceptance of nezuko happens
and tanjio's recovery from his
incredible fight
and all within this single arc in the
movie it covers the character
development of
rengoku the fire pillar has an insane
amount of personal growth for tanjiro
and gives us enough fights to leave
absolutely nothing left to desire at the
end of the movie
and i think part of that is of course
due to the insane animation
as i was saying earlier ufotable
continues time and time again to get
better
to just show off how great they are at
animating
they're genuinely parts of the movie
that can pass off as like a real
non-animated film which you would expect
to be jarring but somehow these parts
work so well together with the fights
and the cg in the rest of the movie
i'm pretty sure if you looked at this
whole movie frame by frame not
a single one would be lacking animation
wise it was that well done
just from the stunning simple scenery
like in tanjiro's dream world to
rengoku's battle with such intense
swordsmanship and flames going
everywhere ufotable really crossed every
t
and dotted every single eye when they
were producing this movie
not to mention the soundtrack
accompanying it all was also just
beautiful being in the theater and
hearing anime ost music on the big
surround
sound is already a great experience
alone but it made
action scenes so much more intense and
emotional scenes so much more emotional
i'd be interested to see how the movie
felt when it wasn't in a theater if you
were just watching it on your phone at
home
i doubt it would have packed the same
impact but i mean the movie was still
great without all of that extra pizazz
but with all those logistics out of the
way let's get into the meat of it the
story how it was paced
and all of that sweet delectable
goodness
i said this earlier but this arc when i
read it in the mango was
already amazing it ups the stakes of
demon slayer so much
and really kicks off the mood for the
rest of this series after season 1.
now what i'm about to say is kind of a
hot take considering ren goku
is probably the best part of this arc in
most people's eyes
but the part that i love most about
mugen train is tanjiro's character
development
because honestly i was thinking about it
and the series could have probably gone
without really
ever addressing tonjiro's dead family
ever again
and gotten away with it with how large
of a time span the series covers and how
quickly it escalates in season one
i think that most of us probably did
forget about what started this whole
story and where tanjiro came from
but this arc goes out of its way on top
of being chock
full of stuff like an upper moon and
pillar all-out battle
to conclude a sub-arc of tanjiro's that
makes his character
feel so much more wholesome and human
of course i'm not spoiling anything like
i said but the dream world sequence
really allowed us to witness
you know what could have been what
tandro has really lost and to what
extent he will go
to not just avenge his family but to
protect
all he has left nezuko the part where
tanjiro is constantly getting put to
sleep and then escaping immediately
after
is easily my favorite part of the movie
the way that it shows his willpower and
mental strength and
fighting prowess really makes him stand
out to me more than the whole first
season did honestly
and nezuko zenitsu and inosuke do take a
backseat in his arc
definitely which i honestly think is
good just because it's already stacked
to the limit with action and character
development for tanjiro
and rengoku they all definitely get
their moments though enough to make me
happy
and they were always involved even if
they were just smaller roles like comic
relief or just covering side enemies or
whatever
and now let's get into rengoku the real
star of this arc
again this arc is really good standalone
in a compressed movie format
and i think this is most obvious from
the fact that rengoku goes from a
complete stranger to us
to probably a fan favorite in the span
of like two hours
witnessing the ideals of a pillar his
backstory and what has made him into the
strong man he is now
and seeing this come to fruition in an
all-out fight to finish off the movie is
just
untouchable the way that parallels were
drawn between rengoku and tanjiro
is also just great you can really see
their relationship develop throughout
this movie and witness just how he
imbues his will into tanjiro
the way that both of their backstories
were explored so deeply in conjunction
with each other
as well as their overwhelming willpower
to fight demons the two of them fed off
each other's strengths and
really brought this movie up to
unprecedented heights
i feel like if tantra's backstory wasn't
fleshed out then it would feel like
rengoku was the main character of this
movie
which i don't think most people would
have a problem with honestly and of
course if rangoku's backstory wasn't
there then
it would definitely be lacking but the
fact that both were there and they
worked so well together
is certainly the biggest strength of
moody train
and yes i will be completely honest with
you guys
i shed a tear at the end i think after
seeing tonjiro scream like that and the
ending talk
everything if you didn't cry then
honestly you're either really impressive
at keeping your feelings in
or you're heartless it was like the
ultimate catharsis
what began as a slow sleepy train ride
ends in this incredibly hype and
emotional finish
marked by the rising of the sun as you
wake up as well from what honestly
felt like a dream like this watching
experience was so
unreal it really did feel like a dream
when i came out of theater and saw the
light of day again
it was fantastic and absolutely worth
the hype
especially when a film is hyped up so
much like moog train was and with anime
fans who
tend to be over critical sometimes
myself included
it's really hard to meet fan
expectations
so to see the overwhelmingly good
reactions was well deserved truly
it makes me really excited for season
two i think the movie has genuinely
converted me into a big fan of this
series and
i can't wait to see how it'll continue
to be adapted
so what did you guys all think i'd like
to hear critiques if there are any
i know today i didn't really say much
bad about it so if you have anything
feel free to comment it nicely down
below this has been the anime culture
corner i hope you enjoyed the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
[Music]